- (speaking Hebrew)
It means "What's up lady,
can I buy you a drink?"
- Milky...
- Snack Pack attack!
- As a Jew, I should be
able to read this package,
but I also dropped out of Hebrew school.
- It looks like cottage cheese, maybe?
- Okay, probably not.
- Kinda smells like hot chocolate.
- This is just chocolate pudding with
whipped cream on top, basically.
- [Girl] It's so good!
- [Guy] It's delicious.
- What a treat.
- Oh, it's so good.
Oh my gosh.
- Alright, Israelis.
- It's ****ing Pop-Rocks in chocolate.
- This looks like it could be dangerous.
- Ain't no fire--
Oh, whoa!
- It crackles in your mouth.
- Oh my god.
- It's like when you're at, like a club,
and you think the party's
over, but it's not,
'cause it's still going
in my mouth right now.
(crackling sound)
- I can hear yours.
- Fred and George Weasley would
totally make something like this.
- [Girl] Bamba Peanut Snack?
- I think that's what
I'm gonna start calling
I don't know, one of
my boyfriends, "Bamba!"
- Bamba means baby, I'm guessing?
- Bamba!
Or basketball.
- They look like Cheetos
but they smell like peanuts.
- These are interesting.
- I do not like it.
- It's like putting a Cheeto in your mouth
and then it turns into peanut butter.
- I hate them, but I want more of them.
- They're flavored wheat snacks.
That's like not an attractive slogan.
(laughter)
- Dude I think we could
dress up like these guys.
- Who are these two cool cats?
- I need an earring, and
a little bit of chin hair.
- I think I got it.
- That smells like falafel!
- Oh my god, it does!
- The shape is not appealing, it's...
honestly like some sort of rodent food.
- I'm really in to these.
- Yeah.
- It's like a good bar snack.
- You could break these down and use them
as breading for fried chicken,
you could put this on
your green been casserole,
you could put it on your salad,
you could put it on your pitas.
- Ice cream sandwiches.
- Live it up!
- [All] Mocha!
- Oh, like a Goomba?
- Yeah, kind of like a Goomba.
- I think it looks a lot like a Diglet.
- You know what, it looks like a Malamar.
- But that looks like a lot of fun inside.
- My question is, what is this?
- The marshmallow is actually
a lot like Marshmallow Fluff.
- There's a cookie at the bottom!
- Delicious, it's just
a little cumbersome.
- Whoever invented this snack,
is just like a master of the craft.
- [Girl] Pesek Zman!
- It's a milk chocolate bar,
filled with wafer and hazelnut cream.
- Mmm! Sounds like Nutella!
- Yeah it looks super gooey
and amazing on the thing,
and then it just sort of looks like fuzzy.
- This is like the
successful, globetrotting
older brother of a KitKat.
- Break me off a piece of that...
Pesek Zman.
- It's good.
We approve, Israel. Good job.
- I wonder if it's really
hard to find Bacon in Israel.
- Yeah, of course it is.
(laughter)
- You would think that, how
like there's kosher places here
that just sell kosher
food, there's un-kosher
places in Israel--
- [Guy] No!
- [Girl] That serves like
bacon and lobsters, and that's it?
- The answer is no.